you know most hotels do rent to rent
Premier in don't own most of their
hotels 95% of them are rent to rent I
took a rent to rent on maybe 3 months
ago a hotel not even a big hotel 34
rooms nice beautiful Cambridge hereare
Hotel rent to rent I'm paying 100 Grand
a year that's bringing me in a profit I
mean I've only had it a few months but
my projections on that are it's going to
bring me in about 150 Grand profit after
all expenses a year on a rental rent and
the great thing is I also have the
option to buy after 10 years but that's
another story you know rent to rent on a
big scale you can easily have uh not
just a million pound company but if
you've got a few of them over a couple
few years you got you got a million
pounds